mais surtout car les escargots les yeux
[ __ ] or la bande dessinée maintenant
elle paraît en plein boom elle j'ai là
trois nouveaux journaux à suivre bd et
puis regard sur le monde et pourtant
l'âge d'or de la bande dessinée par est
dépassée elle tâtonne en ce moment elle
se cherche on le verra ce week-end
encore à toulouse ou hst est un festival
fini les super héros martine
laroche-joubert a trouvé ceux
d'aujourd'hui 100 muscle un petit peu
dérisoire souvent punk bref la bd n'est
plus ce qu'elle était après l'exclusion
des années 60 la bande dessinée semble
manquer de potion magique dans ces
années 60
entraînés par un petit gaulois des cas
près par l'humour acide el hara kiri
elle avait quitté la chambre d'enfant
pour le salon et s'était retrouvé
éléments de notre culture quotidienne
les dessinateurs de bd ce qui s'est
penché sur la société en deux temps deux
idées par les fenêtres de notre train de
vie emporté croyait-il d'art une
nouvelle société d'après mai 68 se
retrouve aujourd'hui sur un butoir la
réalité plus la reprise les ressources
triste leur aventure où la couleur de
murales peut-être que cette espèce de
situation on ne peut plus
vaseuses se retrouve dans mes
personnages dans la psychologie des
personnages qui généralement sont des
perdants sont des personnages sans
espoir et encore une fois qu'ils
contrôlent pas du tout ce qui se passe
autour d'eux atmosphère oppressante dans
la bande dessinée d'aujourd'hui les
héros ce qui nous ressemble
ce qui pourrait marcher dans les rues a
détruit son petit petits bonshommes
entouré de grands grands ensembles
grands personnages et même quand la bd
devient plus politique plus proche de
nos préoccupations actuelles
alors là c'est pire les héros nos frères
deviennent moutons 3 de rapaces
dans la bande des du beurre noir il ya
aussi des politicards véreux il ya aussi
des gens qui équipe font des promesses
pour le changement qui promettent par
exemple de débarrasser les moutons du
baron noir et puis y'a des prétendants
au pouvoir qui disent vous n'avez rien
fait jusqu'à présent
moi je vous débarrasserez du manoir
alors voilà alors tout tourne autour de
cette idée là
quel est le plus menteur les deux devant
l'absence de rêve sur la réalité
les dessinateurs se réfugie dans
l'aventuré dans l'écran ailleurs de la
science fiction mais aussi dans les
brumes des légendes dans la mémoire des
régions ban de brotonne bones occitane
et c'est là la grande force de la bd
être le récipient privilégié des
diverses des courants qui ne pourraient
s'exprimer ailleurs
non mais je crois que la banque bretonne
que nous faisons est actuel c'est pour
ça que le premier épisode se passe dans
le présent c'est pour bien montrer que
les problèmes ont toujours étaient les
mêmes et que malheureusement ils sont
encore les mêmes 2001 après c'est un
problème de pression des minorités
quelle qu'elle soit par une majorité qui
peut être y majorité militaire ou
politique ou géographe jacques mois par
est un millier de pages de bd titre qui
se font et se défont devant cette
impression de tourner en rond devant la
grisaille apparaît une tentation tout
faire éclater tout nié le récit la page
les dessins
ception de quelques dessinateurs
toujours les mêmes qui songent pas riser
gb mandryka tout le reste me paraît plat
conformiste sans intérêt les seuls vrais
créateurs c'est justement
des jeunes gens qui n'échappe pas
l'atmosphère du mouvement qui sont
dedans totalement ils ont produit des
dessins
ses dessins sont une parodie de cette
époque puisqu'il d kalck ce qui existe
et en décalquant il le parasite est
à telle enseigne qu'aujourd'hui on veut
dire que leur influence est considérable
ces bandes sont les premières bandes pad
comme il ya une musique punk le hard
rock le rock dur c'est la bd dure celle
qui naît dans les lycées et pour astérix
la potion aurait un goût amer peut-être
l'amertume de se sentir venir